and why do i sell this because i
literally
moved from you know new york right
investment banking
a great career trajectory and i said you
know i want to
invest and vest my career in early stage
israeli technology companies welcome to
20-minute leaders
just sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance opposed labs touring
hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with
c-tech we are in the viola offices in
herzeglia and i'm joined by umriben
david general partner of viola ventures
he joined the fund in 2017 bringing with
him 15 years of technology-focused
experience across investment banking
startup operations and both
institutional and private venture
investments
prior to viola omri was a senior vice
president and goldman sachs in the tech
media and telecom investment banking
group
omrie's areas of investment and viola
ventures include fintech and insure tech
as well as enterprise and
sme software i'm riben david welcome to
20 minute leaders
thanks for having me we are in the
beautiful viola offices
in herzliya we're staring at a beautiful
landscape here in the city and
you know walking into the offices it
feels like i'm in a huge startup that is
just
you know growing immensely and then
there's a stark vibe and
with open spaces with conference rooms
don't imagine this
being a traditional venture capital
office and the first thing that you
mentioned to me is that on this side we
have viola fintech on this side we have
yola growth
it's amazing yeah it's an empire who are
you
so um the viola group we've been around
for 21 years
uh we are the largest tech focused
investment firm in israel
managing more than three billion dollars
three
billion three billion dollars and we do
so
across four families of funds that you
mentioned some of them right so i'm a
partner at viola ventures we'll talk
about that in a second
we are the early stage side of the house
we
used to be called carmel ventures for
the audience up until three years ago
then we rebranded to be part of the
you know the viola kind of consistent
branding
but we do have a growth fund we have a
late stage co-investment
fintech fund and we have a credit fund
and we
occasionally work together on the front
end
but more importantly you know the group
invested in more than 200 companies
we leverage what we call the economies
of scale you know the platform and
that's what you've seen
out here and that's the ability to you
know connect people
and finding a poc design and
leverage the network and position for
the next round
and uh you know we have shared services
like uh
hr for recruiting and biz dev and uh
marketing
and legal and finance etc and we try to
bring
all that to bear to help our our
founders you know to help our companies
we're going to dive deep into into
hopefully all that in just a second but
first i want to dissect you a little bit
yeah
you didn't start your your investment uh
experience with viola or with carmel
take me back all the way to new york and
a little bit what what led you to even
understand that that you want to do this
that you want to be sitting here
working with over 200 companies yeah on
some of the most amazing things
yeah so uh it's actually interesting uh
story i think maybe not uh
not uh you know the usual suspect uh so
to speak
so i've been in viola for four years i i
lead here
just for contacts mostly uh b2b software
broadly defined and fintech investments
prior to joining i lived in new york as
you mentioned for 10 years
i went to do my mba columbia business
school
and then i worked for yeah small school
in new york
and then i i worked for goldman sachs as
a tech investment banker for nine years
so i was much more suited up than you
see me today with a polo shirt
um and uh and there you know you do your
classic uh
banking uh deals uh we do mergers and
acquisitions you know my claim to fame
is when we sold directv to att
for 67 billion and we took endurance
public and we helped
variant here in israel and uh we bought
constant contact
and uh sold uh dynatrace and compuware
lots of you know big interesting
transactions
and you do tech companies public which
is now the flavored azure in israel
so you do ipr road shows and you write
swans etc
and of course debt underwriting and
activism rate defense
but also 10 of the job in banking at
goldman
was institutional investments so we
invested again in small companies like
uber
and spotify and zocdoc and uh and many
others
but it wasn't 100 of the of the job
obviously and i was also
an angel investor at yc and i think this
transition
was kind of the classical you know sell
side to buy side so from advisory and
execution
at the highest levels really to uh to
start up investments etc and i think the
other portion of it is before new york
um
so i'm not 8200 although i was a mentor
in the 8200 accelerator i don't know how
they
accepted me in there uh i went to
meta you know kind of an infantry unit
that was a company commander there
but i'm undergrad computer science uh
television university
and i worked in um in a young
uh startup called jungle software uh
through school and afterwards kind of
leading sales marketing and biz dev so
also kind of the operating experience of
working in a startup scaling it up and
of course selling it
successfully at the end kind of all this
came to uh
karma to join viola for four years ago
unbelievable this transition from being
institutional investor uber those types
of companies angel investor
in y combinator two complete extremes
of of investment behavior analysis and
thinking
also of acceptance of who you're
investing in yeah
that talk to me about that transition
yeah so i'll tell you why we tell also
our investors you know rlp is in the
fund uh
basically we are big believers in the
israeli tech ecosystem you know israel
used to be called
startup nation uh we now call it kind of
unicorn country you know with almost 50
unicorns we by the way have
seven of them if i may do a commercial
break just viola ventures
uh i think it's the most well i know
it's the most out of
all the israeli early stage funds
and that's part of our thesis and we can
talk about this but we now believe that
israel is going from unicorn nation to
become
uh you know the era of decacor see iron
source in our portfolio
but also etoro and wix that we talked
about them earlier
uh and of course platika and uh uh
mobili which was the largest exit at
15.3 you see more and more examples of
israel
uh um going and sort of developing or
generating those types of success
stories what we call
global category leaders and why do i
sell this because
i literally moved from you know
new york right investment banking a
great career trajectory
and i said you know i want to invest and
vest my career
in early stage israeli technology
companies
and that's a big statement and that's
what we tell our lps look israel
is the place to be right now and you
talked to me about experiences that sort
of shaped my
uh who i am and i think the idea of
moving back with children all born there
you know having a good life comfortable
life right in in the us
um and kind of fulfilling the prophecy
or
or basically you know not only selling
that thesis but also living by it right
and i think that's uh
um that's a testament of the strength of
this ecosystem here
so that conviction of what you're
bringing with you that
what it sounds to me is that you know
you chose the the unordinary path you
had any
one one specific path that you were on
you took the less comfortable one
and and part of that is the conviction
that you bring with you to viola
now when you meet with with companies
like the seven that you're that are
already unicorns and you're meeting new
companies on a daily basis
how does that conviction play into your
own thesis of
of who do you want to work with and what
types of companies you want to invest in
yeah so first you know the earlier you
go and invest in companies and you know
this
it's more about the team it's not a
cliche it really is i mean you wanna
uh you wanna uh find a team and you want
that team to find you
to be somebody they wanna work with
right it's uh it's literally you know
i've been married for many years but
it's literally
like a wedding right it's uh your
partner uh and by the way it's your
partner in the ups but also in the downs
and you want to be somebody
you know in your corner just to use this
uh uh boxing analogy
uh that you know they say everybody has
a plan and they get punched in the face
but also when you get punched in the
face
you wanna look back and say oh this is
the guy or girl of course that i wanna
be in my in my corner in my side so i
think the first element is of course the
team
then you look at other things you know
seed you look at team and you look at
sort of is the market interesting enough
is this a category that matters right is
this uh is this a category that can get
uh disrupted you know vector-wise you
know the earlier you go you don't really
have that
product market fit yet and of course
then you go into
how you you know what are your moats in
terms of technology and product etc
and then there are other things you look
at but i think important for us
and again we we invest in each fund you
know 20 to 25
investments right early stage
investments um you quickly realize
that the vc model works if you manage to
generate those
outliers so we don't live by a hit ratio
strategy we live
by an outlier strategy and that means
it's not always successful actually most
of the time it's not successful but we
want to be
in a room working with a team that we
believe and they believe
and they have the conviction that they
can lead an interesting category
and if that happens everybody is happy
and look at the type of
successes we had and frankly other funds
in israel had and entrepreneurs
and that success uh leads to more and
more success it's this vicious cycle
you know the uh entrepreneurs are the
rock stars of this uh
of this century or this decade and you
know the younger people they want to be
like them
and they do a first exit and the second
and the third and it's
uh it's an amazing ecosystem of
innovation that israel is just blessed
with
so you're talking about this guy or girl
that when you get punched in the face
you want to look back and be able to
fall back on because they'll push you up
now viola one of the things that we
started talking about right before we
started recording is this whole
ecosystem that you're building yeah
economies of skill but also you know
the actual tangible ways in which you're
supporting the portfolio companies well
beyond just
the the bank transfer that happens on
signing the check
so how does how do you actually work
with startups on a day-to-day basis how
does a startup working with viola
experience viola across their lifetime
so i'll tell you what
uh what is uh well we try to be our kpi
okay
i wanna you know for you for example the
entrepreneurs out there to go out
and ask you know entrepreneurs you work
with uh
who is your uh most uh impactful board
members or who is your partner in this
journey
uh that you would uh go and you know be
your sound board or get good advice or a
good introduction
uh or whatever that is you need right i
you know with entrepreneurs it's their
company
it's very important to uh understand
that we're not there to interfere
but we are there to be helpful when they
come into a place where they say hey
look i have
these two alternatives i would like to
hear your two cents and
our kpi is if you go to our
entrepreneurs
and they tell you look uh viola around
my table you know i run my my boxing
match just to use the same analogy for
this discussion
viola and the partner at viola ventures
is the person is my go-to guy and if we
did this
then we've done something right right
and i think
you know the way you work with them it's
not as structured as people
uh tend to think i mean it's like
mentorship right it's not there is the
answer
the structured and the unstructured
there's no point telling somebody hey
i'm going to meet you on a weekly basis
the unstructured is what makes it
successful
and the communication could be uh in
person meetings and
zoom and what's up and whatever that may
be but if you're instilling them the
fact that
anything you need from hiring an exec
to let's talk about the positioning for
the next round
let's talk about our pricing our go to
market strategy let's talk about the
business model let's talk about uh
you know who should we reach out to for
our next fundraise and we would like to
get this warm intro from you guys
um to you know personal
things that happen you know because
ultimately
if they come to me or to us then that's
a success
and i think you know people people say
this but i think it's true for the ceos
out there
it's a pretty lonely job yeah you know
they are
there he or she are sitting in their
offices they make a thousand decisions a
day
everybody makes mistakes they want to
minimize them but you want to be
that person that they can reach out to
interact with
listen to and be that that you know
helpful
person for them so as you're sitting
personally on board with some of the
most amazing companies and using
startups here in the ecosystem
where does it meet you personally like
what part what part of
me does it meet when you're working with
different ceos
so so look my background in banking as i
mentioned you know your typical
trajectory would probably be
you know go and do private equity yeah
right go and do
uh something that is much more uh growth
stage
uh than early stage i think my
mission or what uh what gives me energy
and wants me to wake up
every morning is the early stage side of
things and why is that because i think
ultimately we talked about this earlier
but when you have a team
and a market you want to go after i
believe the earlier you go
the five to ten decisions you get right
at the beginning of your journey are
gonna pretty much
not dictate but are gonna help project
your trajectory
whether it's going to be hockey stick or
whether it's going to be more linear
or god forbid it's going to be more
lumpy than than linear
you know up and to the right and my
passion
is to be with entrepreneurs when they
make those five to ten decisions
and i think that's what you know both
from working at startups
and you know being a computer science
undergrad and
working with entrepreneurs if they allow
me to work with them
on those five to ten decisions some of
them we mentioned earlier
but they have to do again with hiring
and design and finding the right design
partners and you know the product market
fit and what is the business model you
know
it used to be license maintenance and
everybody was you know let's do sas
now maybe it's uh value-based pricing
right and you got to be
you got to be with them at all these you
know junctions and
there aren't 50 of them there are five
to ten of them and that's my passion to
work with them to make sure
that the trajectory is you know a j
curve
as much as possible i love that analogy
that as you're building the foundation
you know you they're going to be making
the same number of decisions across the
lifetime of the company from
inception to ipo but the 510 decision on
day one
are exponentially more critical than the
five to ten decisions at the end
because they simply impact the way
dozens of people are later going to
enact on those decisions right
no that's right infrastructure is the
right way to look at it it's like the
mass slow thing get the basics
and then you go up uh on those ladders
uh
based on your own progress right and
your own i mean
companies always have different issues
when there are different stages
obviously
but again to my um my passion and that's
why i wanted to do early stage is to get
at the uh ground level and help you know
kind of the companies go
all the way all the way up what are you
experiencing that is something that
perhaps is non-trivial that if you look
back at omari that's finishing his time
in new york
before even joining it as an angel to yc
what is something that you're learning
about
the early stage ecosystem whether it's
in israel or the world they're saying
wow this
i did not think this is how things are
working you know that's why i use the
the team everybody says team is
important yeah i'm telling you
one of my lessons learned is if you
don't keep
the bar as high as possible in terms of
your hiring
you're not going to be successful you
need to have around the table
a plus people talents in every single
function in your organization because
what happens and i've seen it again and
again and i didn't emphasize it enough
so
for the entrepreneurs out there don't
ever compromise
on hiring because what happens is it
could be a slippery slope
you're an entrepreneur and you're hiring
a b player
that b player may hire a c player and it
will go down and down that
uh that funnel and especially now i know
it's difficult the market is
is very competitive right now like super
competitive
but the the one lesson learned is um
again do not compromise and make sure
that you hire
the best team that you can uh sounds
trivial
but people because they get pressure
from their board or from their
leadership team
yeah uh they say you know we have to
hire now and they they cut corners
and that it just doesn't uh it just
doesn't work
so that brings me to accountability
which is a beautiful word by the way it
doesn't exist in hebrew
really think about it what's the word
for accountability in hebrew
but it's a beautiful world think about
it later i i love this word by the way
and it's a thing that i am i'm stumped
by this idea how does one keep
themselves accountable because it seems
like every
every function in the company is
including the investors
they need to be held accountable by some
other function
and so how do you experience
accountability whether it's from
vc to to ceo perspective or
ceo to himself or vc to yourself how
does accountability actually work
properly when it does yeah so first of
all in my view
accountability is an inherent uh
proposition
okay so i want to be accountable
in my own sort of uh little world and i
expect the entrepreneurs to be
accountable
in their own little world and it's it's
of course there is this uh relationship
you know this two-way street between us
but i don't think a person can make
another person accountable
if that specific individual does not
feel accountability
or ownership i just think it's something
that is is a
super um important trait for a
successful entrepreneur
and again i'm still shocked that there
is no word for this in hebrew but it's
something that needs to come
a little bit from the inside and then
i'm happy to be accountable for you
and you're probably happy to be
accountable for me because that's what
partnership is all about right
and our you know our slogan so to speak
is to be you know impactful partners and
the word partner
is is there on purpose to exceptional
entrepreneurs
and part of being that exception is
owning you know your successes
your mistakes uh but um you know this is
a grown-up games right i mean this is
not uh we are
in a serious world we are we're trying
to change the world with technology and
innovation
yeah and we all need to be um you know
accountable again for
our our actions for our our good our bad
and we are by the way
happy to be there in that journey again
for better or worse till
as i say till death or exit do us part
this is amazing and you know i'm so sad
that you can't see behind
behind these walls because that what's
happening here is just it's just
fascinating and i appreciate it you know
viola comes up on a daily basis
here in the ecosystem and the amazing
things that you do the amazing
entrepreneurs that you support and
a lot of them are good friends of mine
and i keep hearing how amazing it is so
so thank you for this for this time and
this inspiration yeah i have a few
questions not about
your your journey not about viola but
about your personality a little sure
take me back to middle school or high
school
you're sitting in the class what what
fascinates you as a kid
yeah you know so an anecdote yesterday
was my 25th reunion
uh high school union okay i'm i'm 42
i'm a class of uh 1996. but it gets
better i'm uh
born i'm a kid of uh uh exactly
um good i'm i'm a kid of international
upbringing by the way that's another
thing that shaped me
a lot i i think israel is is a is a
great country
you know nine million people uh plenty
of innovation
but you have to have you know your
lenses way more open
and you know that because you lived
abroad uh as well obviously so that's
another
experience but anyway that was my my
25th um
uh reunion it was uh in zoom kovid i
don't know if you watched this in five
years
go google what coffee it was but uh i
so but when i graduated in frankfurt i
went to the frankfurt international high
school
i think i played against you in tennis
many many years later in the isst iss of
course
i i went to frankfurt to play tennis and
volleyball no way and
we were rivals we're still rival schools
amazing so uh
the the guy the the big coach of all the
sports program was in this iranian as
well
uh but my math teacher was there as well
mrs shoebottom who i have to uh i have
to get in touch with her i also told her
that uh over there
she uh she had this amazing video kind
of wishing us all success
and that we continue to be uh ambitious
and
you know the isst so you know i did the
international baccalaureate and i did
math high
of course but i know it sounds geeky but
i
i loved i loved math back then and i'm
still a person
of uh of numbers look i was a banker too
right so uh
i um numbers are not i'm not strange to
uh um
uh strangers to numbers if you look
across your journey some
some figure metaphorical or real that
that inspires you
either personally professionally yeah
look i am
i i'm not gonna go i'm not gonna go big
on um
uh on you know kind of famous uh tech
people and so on i think
something that is much more personal and
again it comes back to israel
look israel is about 72 years old give
or take
um i am um i'm a first generation that
was born in israel despite
you know half my life living abroad um
i am i'm gonna give this to uh my
grandparents
from both sides of uh of my parents
for them to leave everything behind and
it doesn't matter really if it was
one side uh from europe uh and the other
side
uh uh from uh you know north africa for
example
i think all of us in israel uh part of
our dna
our innovation the fact that they left
everything to come here
and create this amazing country
uh and not only survive but thrive
i i'm i'm really i'm gonna give him this
they're they're they're gone right
they passed all four of them but i gave
it to my my grandparents
beautiful and if i were to ask anybody
in this office
or if i would ask you how would you
describe yourself
in three words look i think again to the
entrepreneurs so
um i'm always on always on always on
um i'm you know accessible reachable
uh try to do whatever i can to uh
help second i'm a big believer in
integrity
i think he goes both professional
integrity but also personal integrity
uh and uh i'm committed i'll be
committed to this success i'll do
whatever i can
uh to uh to help entrepreneurs and
really work with them
uh to make it happen and it sounds like
also committed to the failure
and always there we will be there again
for um better or worse till death or
exit do us part that's important
thank you very much it was great thank
you
[Music]